As we all know, Netflix giveth, and Netflix
taketh away and lo and behold, it's taking
away quite a few really great flicks during
March 2020.
It can be difficult to keep track of all the
comings and goings on Netflix, but fortunately
for you, we're on top of it.
Most of Marvel Studios' releases have already
boogied off of Netflix and onto their new
home on rival streamer Disney+, and the stragglers
won't be around for long.
As of now, you can still catch Avengers: Infinity
War, Ant-Man and the Wasp, and Black Panther
on Netflix but if you're keen to relive King
T'Challa's awesome 2018 solo adventure, you'd
better do it pretty soon.
Time's running out, so don't freeze.
"I never freeze."
Star Chadwick Boseman gives a powerful, regal
performance, his co-stars Danai Gurira and
Letitia Wright deliver star-making turns,
and Michael B. Jordan brings to life one of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe's most complex
villains to date.
Black Panther is one of Mighty Marvel's greatest
films, and that is really saying something.
Stream it on Netflix until March 3.
The franchise may have flagged a bit with
last year's soft reboot Men in Black: International,
but the first three films in the MiB series
the ones which benefited from the sure direction
of Barry Sonnenfeld and the otherworldly comedic
chemistry of stars Tommy Lee Jones and Will
Smith are about as good as sci-fi comedies
get.
The first two of those, 1997's Men in Black
and 2002's Men in Black II, are available
for streaming on Netflix, but not for long.
If you haven't caught either of these flicks
for awhile, it will amaze you to be reminded
just how fun and funny they are especially
the first one.
Smith's ever-inflating charisma and star power
is on full display, Jones is as cool as ever,
and supporting players such as Linda Fiorentino,
the late Rip Torn, Lara Flynn Boyle, and Johnny
Knoxville round out the supporting casts of
Men in Black and Men in Black II; watch them
again on Netflix until March 14.
Coraline is an innovative animated film which
everyone assumes was directed by Tim Burton,
but was actually the work of Henry Selick,
one of Burton's longtime associates and director
of the holiday classic The Nightmare Before
Christmas.
Based on a novel by master of dark fantasy
Neil Gaiman the mind behind the iconic comic
book series The Sandman Coraline goes to some
very unusual places, not the least of which
is the alternate dimension visited by its
child protagonist.
"No way!
You're not sewing buttons in my eyes!"
"Oh, but we need a 'Yes!' if you wanna stay
here."
"So sharp, you won't feel a thi-Ow!"
Basically, it's a stunning visual and narrative
achievement, one which you'll want to catch
again before its time on Netflix is up and
if you've never seen it, you'll probably want
to get on that.
Coraline is available to stream until March
15.
David Fincher's 2007 masterpiece Zodiac is
several cuts above your average true-crime
thriller; meticulously researched, flawlessly
written, and featuring a crackerjack cast
made up largely of, coincidentally, future
MCU alumni, the movie provides an exhaustive
examination of the Zodiac murders, perhaps
the most notorious unsolved serial killings
in American history.
Like the real-life case, it's agonizingly
suggestive without providing answers; also
like the case, it can at times slow to a crawl
before catching the viewer totally off-guard
with shocking, punishing bursts of violence.
David Fincher's direction has never been sharper
or more deliberate.
Stream Zodiac on Netflix until March 19.
The films of director Christopher Nolan's
Dark Knight trilogy are some of the finest
examples of the superhero genre, and they
blazed more trails than you might remember.
Before 2005's Batman Begins, the word "reboot"
was used solely to describe the process of
restarting a computer; Nolan's complete revamping
of Batman for the big screen was gritty, grounded,
and inspired, even if its took audiences forever
to get their heads around the fact that it
was not a sequel to the Tim Burton or Joel
Schumacher Batman movies.
"It's not who I am underneath, but what I
do that defines me."
"Bruce?"
The film's legacy would have been impressive
enough on its own, but then came 2008's The
Dark Knight, which simply shattered everyone's
notions of what a comic book film could be.
Sadly, all good things as they say must come
to an end.
Gotham's protector won't be sticking around
for much longer.
Batman Begins and The Dark Knight will be
available to stream until March 30.
Spectacle movies don't get much more spectacular
than Peter Jackson's Lord of the Rings trilogy,
and the second and third films The Two Towers
and The Return of the King are revered by
fans of J.R.R.
Tolkien's classic fantasy novels.
Sure, Return of the King ends about six different
times, but fans didn't mind; heck, the movie
was so good that they probably would have
been fine with two or three more fakeout endings.
Mind-blowingly staged and perfectly cast,
the Lord of the Rings flicks set a standard
for big-budget fantasy that no movie without
Harry Potter in the title has even come close
to approaching.
Unfortunately, the end is nigh.
You'd best feast your eyes on the final two
films in the greatest fantasy series of all
time before it's too late.
The Lord of the Rings: The Two Towers and
The Lord of the Rings: The Return of the King
will be departing Netflix on March 30.
Its five sequels have provided somewhat diminishing
returns, but it's hard to overstate what a
revelation Paranormal Activity was when it
hit screens in 2007.
Its inspired tweak to the conventions of the
found-footage genre: all of the action takes
place on cameras which a young couple set
up throughout their home in an attempt to
record, well, the paranormal activity plaguing
the joint, allowed it to be made on a shoestring
budget.
This a) in no way kept it from being the scariest
film of its year, and b) made its $193 million
worldwide box office total even more impressive
than if the film hadn't been made for the
cost of a pretty nice used car.
"You know what, there's footsteps in but there's
no footsteps out."
"Oh, God."
Director Oren Peli masterfully ratchets up
the tension during the film's scant 85-minute
run time, and then-unknown stars Katie Featherston
and Micah Sloat turn in realistic performances
that make the frequent scares land that much
harder.
With an excruciating third act and a final
shot guaranteed to separate you from your
skin, Paranormal Activity is one of the very
best found-footage flicks ever made; stream
it on Netflix until March 30.
As a director, Quentin Tarantino is every
bit as skilled as he is wildly unrestrained,
and we love him for both of those qualities.
Kill Bill Vol. 1 and Kill Bill Vol. 2 are
very much two halves of one big movie, and
it is part kung-fu flick, part revenge movie,
and all Tarantino.
Uma Thurman stars as Beatrix Kiddo AKA "The
Bride" a master assassin and once a key member
of the feared Deadly Viper Assassination Squad.
She is brutalized and left for dead on her
wedding day by her former cohorts, including
their leader, Bill, who responds to her plea
to spare her life and the life of their unborn
child by shooting her in the head.
Over the course of the two movies, she exacts
her revenge on the Squad's members without
mercy, eventually fulfilling the flicks' titles
by way of the Five Point Palm Exploding Heart
Technique.
"You're a terrific person.
You're my favorite person.
But every once in a while, you can be a real
c----."
The Kill Bill flicks are pure, distilled Tarantino
which is to say that they are uber-cinematic,
super-stylized, unbelievably violent fun.
They are two of the straight-up craziest movies
you will ever see, and you've only got so
much time left to see them on Netflix; Kill
Bill Vol. 1 and Kill Bill Vol. 2 will be leaving
the streamer on March 30.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.